Twitter is a very interesting phenomenon
because you get all kinds of things
going on on it it's not just one thing
you have people writing haiku on it you
have people yelling at other people and
they probably should realize that
twittering is publishing and you can end
up with a libel suit on your hands that
hasn't quite sunk in yet in some areas
but it's true
so it's blogging so people are
interacting in these unprecedented sorts
of ways that were not possible before
the invention of social medium like this
and we're in the early stages of it the
good sides of it are for instance if you
want the answer to a question and you
put it out there you'll get the answers
some of them may be wrong but you'll get
a whole bunch of answers and you can
then sift through them and and see which
ones fit your question if you want to
help with something and people often
send out cries for help for their
various causes over Twitter and works
for that too so there all kinds of good
uses for it and everything has a dark
side there are bad uses for it - and
that's doesn't depend on the technology
it depends on the users but the
technology does facilitate a kind of
instant communication that can just go
viral and become a news story so Twitter
is now part of the news Twitter is now
part of people making news and all of
the news outlets have got their blogs
and and online versions and Twitter
feeds
there's all kinds of good tweets some of
them are just people replying to others
people people's questions sometimes you
get a joke going for instance during the
Canadian Olympics the Canadians were
saying on the podium and I put out
something that said oh it's a bit brash
to say it's a bit unconnected am the
podium what do you suggest and the
Twitter folks piled on with all these
pretty hilarious subject suggestions
that they could follow by a hashtag that
said see podium so they're saying things
like a podium for me rent the podium
maybe squeeze over a little bit so I can
just snuggle up to the podium so they
went on like that for a while and right
now we seem to be proposing a turnip for
Canadian Prime Minister due to a remark
I made in an article saying that I would
vote for a turnip if it were transparent
accountable listen to people and was a
parliamentary Democrat so the turnip is
now under some pressure to become a
write-in candidate or possibly even to
felt form its own party but being a
vegetable it's taking a bit of time to
think this over
meanwhile we are we're learning a bit
about it this does turnip its likes and
dislikes and it did go to a publishing
lunch today to discuss its book deal
he's not usually this the some this
spiffy-looking
he put on his special New York outfit to
go to the publishing lunch you can see
it's it looks a bit like a cabbage but
but that's that's what's in this season
for turnips and he didn't have a nice
lunch and I think he's going to my
reading and interview tonight at the
92nd Street Y and I expect that he'll be
in Portland Oregon I'm talking to Ursula
Gwyn and I think he's going to
Portsmouth New Hampshire where he hopes
to meet with Stephen King I shouldn't
say he because he actually doesn't have
a gender I should say yet
yet he's a know around candidate